[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir ici alexis ii
lancèrent c'est avec plaisir qu'on vous
souhaite la bienvenue à cette émission
toute spéciale entièrement consacré au
retour sur terre de l'astronaute
canadienne david saint jacques
il s'apprête à amorcer au cours des
prochaines minutes de son entrée dans
l'atmosphère et ce après 204 jours
passés dans l'espace
l'atterrissage du vaisseau soyouz dans
les steppes du kazakhstan est prévu vers
22 heures 48 55 secondes comprenez bien
que tout cela est réglé au quart de tour
restez donc avec nous pour ne rien
manquer de ce moment important va le
vivre ensemble en images en direct avec
nos collaborateurs sur place là bas au
kazakhstan est également en studio c'est
parti il ya trois choses qu'on fait avec
le peu de temps libre
quand elles faisaient un gymkhana ont
fait de la science ont fait des heures
entre d'exploration
on y voit
[Musique]
parce que l'avenir de ne m'étais pas ce
soir
et c'est la fin d'un long chemin
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est que vous pouvez voir
une maison les plus prisées de la
chlamydia l'emploi qui a comme un nuage
dur ici c'est ma chambre
[Musique]
de sentir le vin sur mon visage
m
alors frissons garantis est pour l'heure
qui s'en vient et ça se poursuivra par
la suite deux étapes par étapes lors de
cette par portion très périlleuse de son
aventure david saint jacques le disez
lui-même c'est certainement la portion
la plus dangereuse de toute son aventure
spatiale ce qu'on vend ce moment ce sont
des images en direct du centre de
contrôle russe située à corps relève en
périphérie de moscou ça fait partie des
centraux des lieux névralgiques de ce
qui se passe en ce moment il ya bien
bien entendu baïkonour ya les steppes du
kazakhstan où atterrira éventuellement
sans deux trackers sont pépins on
l'espère la capsule soyouz houston aussi
où on surveille ça de très très près il
ya d'ailleurs les proches les proches de
david saint-jacques ses amis
quelques-uns de ceux qui font partie de
son cercle restreint qui sont là qu'ils
attendaient patiemment et il ya bien sûr
plus près de chez nous l' agence
spatiale canadienne voyons images en
direct d'ailleurs de ces des locaux du
quartier général disons le de l' agence
spatiale canadienne il ya notre collègue
sébastien desrosiers qui se trouve sur
place
il ya des qs astronautes canadiens qui
se trouvent sur place il ya des gens qui
accompagnent depuis le début détail est
vraiment dans le menu détail le périple
de david saint jacques on s'y rendra
d'ailleurs à l' agence spatiale
canadienne ponctuellement à plusieurs
reprises au cours de cette émission
spéciale à mes côtés j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir ici ben charles tisseyre
animateur de l'émission découverte
bonsoir charles alexis allart est aussi
olivier hernandez qui directeur du
planétarium rio tinto alcan astro
physicien de formation ce qui va être
très utile n'est ce pas ce soir mais
voit soir à vous bonsoir
alors on va quand même mettre les choses
en place en ce moment là on en est où
dans ce processus mais ce charme bien en
fait
21h55 ils ont actionné leur gros moteur
largo la grosse rétrofusées qui radotent
si le soulier aux kings a acquis à l'est
à 28 milles kilomètres à l'heure et il
faut allant tir de soyouz pour qu'ils
puissent adopter sa trajectoire est
rentrée dans l'atmosphère et au moment
où on se parle
ça fait quand même quatre minutes à peu
près qu'ils sont en train de rentrer
dans l'atmosphère et léger commence à se
faire sentir les gestes faible se font
légèrement sentir en fait c'est pas
encore tout à fait dans l'atmosphère
sont environ à 140 kilomètres je pense
le le ils viennent de faire leur
allumage doit de cinq minutes là à ce
moment ci et avant de rentrer dans
l'atmosphère il faut qui sépare les
trois modules d'une vaisseau soyouz
parce qu'ils peuvent pas rentrer dans
l'atmosphère avec ça ça va être une
catastrophe sinon et donc ils doivent se
séparer le mot soyouz veut dire union en
fait c'est l'union de trois modules
spatiaux et le module qui nous intéresse
module de descente est au centre et
c'est lui qui va se retourner pour voir
rentrer correctement dans l'atmosphère
c'est ça alors que les deux autres vont
se décomposer et ça fait partie de l'âme
de l'aspect génial de la technologie
russe ce même modèle qui dure et qui
perdure depuis des décennies avec un
taux d'efficacité de succès assez
impressionnant n'est-ce pas loué environ
140 mission je vais maintenant ça qu'il
y est eu vraiment davari importante au
début nous est du programme il y en a eu
oui mais depuis 1971 à peu près ya rien
eu de vraiment grave qui s'est produit
et ils sont en train de don de se
préparer de à rentrer dedans dans
l'atmosphère par le bouclier thermique
qui va protéger la capture et quand elle
va finalement rentrée dans les couches
supérieures mais comme le disait olivier
un instant avant ça il faut que ce très
spatial qui comprend le module de
descente au milieu et d'un côté on a le
module orbital comme un petit salon dans
le fond ne peuvent quand même une salle
de bains imaginer qu'elle le début des
années 60 oui c'est même une toilette
est donc encore d'ailleurs elle est plus
ou moins fonctionnel mais c'est quand
même mieux qu'une couche parce que nos
astronautes dans la navette spatiale et
en eau couches il mettait avant 4 5
jours pour aller la station spatiale
enfin la station mir à l'époque aller
vers la station spatiale ensuite et
maintenant on les envoie sur des
trajectoires où ça leur prend six heures
dont ils n'ont pas même pas besoin de se
rendre dans cette danse module là ils
peuvent rester en place six heures assis
dans le module de descente ou de monter
dépendamment du suspense tourner et se
rendre à la station spatiale ou
retourner sur quoi c'est ça un confort
qui est accrue mais reste que l'entrée
dans l'atmosphère c'est là où très
certainement le niveau de nervosité sera
un peu plus élevé même pour ces
personnes qui sont entraînés et
surentraînés même pour ce type depuis
rep l'on voit tout de suite se tourner
vers longueuil le station pas la station
spatiale internationale mais non c'est
plutôt sébacées desrosiers l agence
spatiale canadienne voilà vous êtes bien
entouré vous aussi il ya beaucoup
d'action de fébrilité j'imagine sur
place quelle est l'atmosphère qui règne
ouais voilà il ya des membres de la
famille de david saint jacques qui sont
ici des employés de l'agencé spatiale
canadienne et d
évitez donc sont réunis ici par dizaines
pour assister à ce moment historique
beaucoup de fébrilité même de
l'électricité dans l'air je vous dirais
parce que pour eux aussi c'est la fin
d'un long périple en quelque sorte comme
pour david saint-jacques bien sûr qu'à
passer 204 jours en orbite autour de la
terre
doit-on le rappeler c'est la plus longue
mission pour un astronaute canadien ce
départ le premier à s'être rendus par
contre sur la station spatiale
internationale
il ya eu bien sûr chris hadfield et
avant eux il ya eu robert thirsk en 2009
qui a fait le même voyage à bord d'une
capsule soyouz que david saint-jacques
effectué aujourd'hui il est ici monsieur
tusk et il nous parle bien brièvement
des souvenirs qu'il garde de cette
journée là la roue tourne au ter sera
n'est moments dramatiques dynamique pour
david
je me souviens très clair très clément à
ma descente dans les soyouz c'était une
chose fou comme comme un cheval qui qui
bouge
alors voilà avec wii avec roberto ce que
pour animer cette soirée
il ya un autre astronaute s'est déjà
remis en scène originaire de l'ontario
un pilote de chasse qui lui a été
recruté par l' agence spatiale
canadienne en 2009 en même temps que
david saint jacques
il s'est entraîné avec lui il attend
toujours sa prochaine mission mais tout
de même il peut nous parler des défis
qui attendent
david et les dvd l'équipe aux taureaux
au cours plutôt de la prochaine heure et
un fond coupe chose qui selon moi je
m'inquiète un peu
le prg mrc le cap serait prêt pour la
rentrée dans l'atmosphère
c'est peut être quelque chose
d'impressionnant avec beaucoup de feux
des choses comme ça et puis après ça
c'est le pire chute ça doit fonctionner
pour avoir un atterrissage qui a travail
alors voilà les deux astronautes qui
s'entendent pour parler de l'importance
qu'a cette mission pour le programme
spatial canadien le lot des bénéfices de
cette mission david saint-jacques me
disait-il basse et d'inspirer les jeunes
canadiens à comme lui aller explorer
l'espace au cours des prochaines années
voilà ça fait partie de son legs de son
héritage david saint jacques
on l'entendra d'ailleurs au cours de
cette émission spéciale dans ses propres
mots parlé de l'importance de cette de
cette mission et de ce que ça peut
inspirer chez les jeunes les jeunes
canadiens merci beaucoup si bastide
érosion vous dira plus tard à plus tard
voilà je vous ferai entendre les gens à
l'intérieur de la salle avec plaisir
voir donc
les prochains jours vont tous se
mélangent activités normales de la
station si on veut des expériences
scientifiques
les activités d'entretien de
l'équipement ça n'arrête pas mais en
parallèle on fait nos bagages donc il
faut surtout pas laisser de traces un
peu comme la règle du camping en cause
il faut pas laisser de traces on peut
prendre des photos mais pas laisser de
traces même chose à bord les proches
l'équipage qui arrivent il faut que je
sois invisible pour eux donc on fait le
tourner les ordinateurs aux équipements
personnels ou vêtements tout ça après ça
on peut ramener quelques objets sur
terre précieux donc dans le soyouz ou
dans une prochaine capsule cargo qui
redescendra donc faut bien pacte est ce
pour se rendre et puis les préparations
et eric je dois étudier beaucoup parce
que toutes les procédures d'un retour
sur terre en soyouz
il faut le maîtriser au bout des doigts
je les maîtrise est il ya neuf mois
quand j'ai fait mes examens de
certification mais il faut bien révisé
alors on passe bhoutan sept ans y est
avec l'équipage s'assurer qu'on a on
revient comme un changement d'esprit là
on est plus il faut s'il faut redevenir
l'équipage de soyouz pour pouvoir
revenir à la maison de manière
absolument sécuritaire et lorsque ça va
se fera pas en quelques heures on va
retomber sur terre littéralement et
après avoir traversé atmosphère ouvert
les parachutes on va atterrir au
kazakhstan on va être récupérée par les
les équipages
des russes et ils vont nous amener à
l'aéroport l on va revenir directement à
houston pour être réuni avec notre
famille alors ça c'était david
saint-jacques la semaine dernière en
conférence de presse si on veut depuis
la station spatiale internationale qui
résumait très bien en capsule est sans
jeu de mots très bien l'essence de son
travail aujourd'hui mais moi ce qui
m'impressionne énormément c'est ce qui
se passe en un mot cette préparation
longue laborieuse méticuleuse de
monsieur saint jean qui est des deux
autres collègues qui l'accompagnent
d'ailleurs on va vous les montrer en
images le visage de ses deux collègues
ainsi que david sait déjà que ceux qui
sont en ce moment même dans cette
capsule et qui tranquillement se prépare
pour son entrée dans l'atmosphère alors
on voit oleg kononov co et qui lui et le
commandant n'est ce pas le copilote cdh
avait de saint jacques a nommé clean et
l'américaine qui était l'ingénieur en
vol n'est ce pas messieurs
oui alors tous et ont un rôle crucial
s'y est jamais eu un pépin mes collègues
coenen causé david saint jacques ne sais
pas qui prend le relais mais revenons
sur cette préparation que david
expliquer dans le détail c'est là où on
voit que tout est chorégraphié dans le
petit sa fonction dans la mesure où on a
tout assimiler cette information
absolument c'est il ya une semaine il
travaillait déjà avec le centre de
contrôle à moscou avec un simulateur à
bord de la station pour justement
vérifier et répéter toutes les étapes
importantes qu'ils auront à traverser en
descendre en descendant dans
l'atmosphère ils ont des gestes a posé
de nombreux gestes à poser il fallait
répéter
ils ont répété aussi hier et avant-hier
alors c'est un processus qui a pris deux
ou trois jours pour simplement se
remettre à niveau que me disait david
saint jacques
même s'il est certifié qualifié pour
piloter de soyouz
il faut qu'il revoit toutes ces étapes
là en détails pour être vraiment à la
hauteur de la situation
en revenant sur terre ce qui est en
train de se produire en ce moment oui on
a un peu l'impression d'être à la fin de
l'année scolaire où il révise ses
classiques avant d'arriver
et se dire bon je dois réussir mes
examens du ministère pour retourner sur
terre à l'heure et évidemment on n'est
pas à l'abri de risques d'erreurs
l'erreur est humaine c'est une vérité
est qu'ils ont et qui prend tout son
sens de contourner dans des
circonstances extrêmes comme celles de
sa vie de ces gens en ce moment tout est
automatisé ou presque ils posent des
gestes dans la capsule qui sont
importants mais c'est le logiciel de la
capsule qui commande la situation s'il
devait y avoir un problème colonel
groupe reprendre les commandes et dirigé
le soyouz lui-même ainsi que david
saint-jacques s'y connaît en cours ne
peut pas le faire mais il ya une
manoeuvre très importante qui s'est
produite donc à 21h55 hantise ont
actionné le moteur principal du soyouz
pour ralentir le fioul ça doit durer 4
minutes 45 secondes
ce set cette action si je puis dire du
moteur principal
il faut pas que ce soit plus long il
faut pas que ce soit plus court parce
que si c'est si ce n'est pas fait
justement à la bonne durée
la capsule pourrait aller aller trop
lentement ou plutôt aller trop vite et
rebondir sur l'atmosphère et se
retrouver dans l'espace plutôt que
pénétrer dans l'atmosphère signer si ce
n'est pas assez ce n'est pas assez ce
n'est pas fait correctement
la capsule pourrait à ce moment là au
lieu de ça des cendres dans l'atmosphère
et suivre une trajectoire trop à pic
ce qui augmenterait les jets à neuf fois
le poids des astronautes à l'intérieur
de la capsule mais surtout augmenterait
la température à l'extérieur ce qui
pourrait être dangereux pour les
astronautes donc si malgré le bouclier
thermique malgré les galères de taille
la thermique cydia jusqu'à quel point
ces manoeuvres là doivent être précises
parce que l'entrée dans l'atmosphère là
c'est qu'on va vivre bientôt là au cours
des prochaines minutes
premier contact vers 22h26 se fait des
températures qui dépassent l'entendement
balles et les frottements sur
l'atmosphère sont
sont assez incroyables et produisent une
chaleur énorme là le bouclier thermique
va monter à une température d'environ
1800 degrés celsius qui est quand même
colossal alors c'est vrai que si la
durée du brûlage avant d'entrer dans
l'atmosphère est trop long ou trop
courte avec la la pente d'entrée dans
l'atmosphère est un petit peu trop
grande à ce moment là la chaleur qui
sera et couches de l'atmosphère qui vont
être traversées devons être plus dense
en fête et de la chaleur va être
dégagées va être beaucoup plus grande et
de facto le nombre de gvt a augmenté et
je crois qu'en 1975 en fait j'ai eu un
incident ah oui oui
lors d'une entrée kkk pas été
préjudiciable aux cosmonautes mais qui
leur a permis d'atteindre des dg au delà
de 10 et 11 même alors c'était cd
colossal c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'assez énorme qu'un pilote de chasse
même a du mal à soutenir et qu'ils ont
dû soutenir tout en ayant passé du temps
dans l'espace et c'est ça la difficulté
c'est que en étant dans l'espace et
passe un certain temps en microgravité
avec une absence totale d'une liberté un
flottement total on ne sort pas du tout
son corps et quand ils vont rentrer dans
l'atmosphère
là ils vont sentir quatre fois leur
propre corps c'est déjà suffisamment
difficile dès lors de le sentir une fois
les ventres sont fait ressentir quatre
fois ça c'est quelque chose de colossal
oui et en fait on approche du moment que
olivier a décrit tout à l'heure c'est à
dire la séparation des modules
oui ça aussi ses critiques parce que
s'ils ne se sépare pas là ils vont
rentrer dans l'atmosphère dans une
mauvaise configuration le module de
descente ne va pas être dans la bonne
position il va être entouré de ses deux
ces deux autres modules qui eux ne sont
pas du tout équipés à résister à la
chaleur de l'atmosphère
et ça ça pourrait poser un énorme
problème ça c'est déjà pensé d'ailleurs
dans le passé du soyouz les trois
modules restent et ils se sont décrochés
ils se sont dit ils se sont décrochés
par la suite en descendant et en
particulier le module de service
peut-être que ceux décrochés simplement
parce qu'il ya un capteur de température
à l'arrière de ce module est si la
température est trop élevée va se
décroche et automatiquement mais au
moins quatre ou cinq manoeuvre
automatique qui permettent justement à
ces modules à de séparer la première ce
sont des petites capsules explosion
devrait d'ailleurs ici charles pour vous
aider à illustrer à nos téléspectateurs
en plus qu'on voit la ligue les trois
portions ou et 3es si on veut modules
dont on parle depuis tout à l'heure elle
donc nous quitte au centre si où se
trouve david saint jacques et ses deux
collègues en ce moment ces modules
le module de descente à rots modèle bd
en haut à gauche on voit le module dit
orbitale qui est un peu leur petit salon
et c'est ce qui permet justement de
s'arrimer à la station spatiale
internationale et à droite si le module
de service où il ya le moteur fusil dont
on a parlé les avionique et l'ordinateur
plus puissant de bord qui leur permet
justement d'atteindre la station
spatiale internationale
lorsqu'ils font l'ascension vers la
station mais mais le module de descente
un ordinateur aussi qui fonctionnent
très fonctionnel en fait un tout petit
ordinateur qui a pas beaucoup de
batteries n'ont plus qu'à une autonomie
très restreinte mais qui en a pas besoin
de plus forcément donc ce petit module b
que l'on voit à l'écran ici ressemble un
petit peu un phare d'avs d'automobiles
en fait et le la partie qui composent le
phare la lune est du phare en fait c'est
le bouclier thermique qui va protéger
les
les astronautes et on le voit comme ça à
l'écran c'est difficile pour nous de
nous d'avoir une idée de l'allemand la
taille de cet engin là de nous ni dit
justement des proportions des longueurs
de ces modules soit environ 2 m 2 mètres
50 le module b abon donc environ 9
mètres je dirais à peu près au total
tous le l'ensemble soyouz qui composent
qu'elle composait des trois modules en
fait bon alors on voit encore une fois
que jack est dans un espace assez
restreint sont à detroit il fait ils
sont pliés un petit peu chacun d'un côté
pour que leur dépôt ne se fige pas il ya
juste la place pour les trois
astronautes
et c'est tout s'il te diriges aussi une
cargaison à bord ils ont toutes sortes
de choses autour de messi s'est
méticuleusement planifié et ça se passe
très très bien
comme disent les russes fsb les neuf
comme on traduit en anglais il conserver
chose si ça marche bien nourri les nord
américains il est toujours en train de
changer
probablement pour que les industries
aéronautiques fasse des profits mais les
soviétiques les russes avaient pas ce
problème
un module qui fonctionne très bien
depuis 40 ans très bien au chaud alors
on va il est 22h19 très précisément on
s'approche de justement de cette
séparation convient de vous décrire en
détail que mais mes collaborateurs et si
viens de vous décrire en détail on va se
quitter le temps d'une courte pause et
on revient avec cette émission spéciale
qui porte sur le retour sur terre je le
rappel de david saint-jacques de suite
il ya deux aspects si on veut médicaux
particulièrement pénible m'ont prévenu
mes collègues expérimentés
d'abord après six mois ici dans l'espace
un sens les effets de la gravité
j'ai appris à voler j'ai appris à me
déplacer dans tous les sens sans aucun
inconfort et techniquement la raison
pour laquelle c'est possible ça c'est
parce que mon oreille interne qui
ressemblait pas la gravité passe comme
si mon cv avait débranché dont j'ai
perdu le sens de l'équilibré
mais ce qui nous permet de paraître
nauséeux ici à bord en orbite je reviens
sur terre la gravité je pense pas que
cette mon ami au début je l'aimais
j'anticipe me sentir un peu vacillant
devoir tenir la main de quelqu'un pour
marcher droit
peut-être n'osais pas d'avoir aussi
problèmes de circulation sanguine tous
les sans couleurs roth
mais dans mes jambes sous l'effet de la
gravité il s'appuie aussi un effet
musculaire aussi un autre aspect j'ai
grandi en l'espace de quelques
centimètres justement parce que ma
colonne vertébrale c'est raide récit
complètement il presque plus de courbure
chaque disque s'était élargie en
ramenant sur terre
je m'écrase et encore c'est à dire
éviter ça il paraît que ça peut être
pénible
donc techniquement ces deux aspects là
que j'ai avec plus ou moins de joie
[Musique]
alors ce qui va manquer d'abord
plusieurs choses
la vue en certainement j'étais encore
juste avant l'entrevue à la cooperl à
regarder défiler l'egypte sous mes yeux
par exemple c'est ce que je voulais voir
donc la vue de la terre de sa beauté
impressionnante sa grâce en fait alors
que l'époux roule comme ça doucement
dans le vide de l'espace
la petite couche bleus de l'atmosphère
qui nous gardent tous envie sentiment de
force tranquille un état de fragilité et
de responsabilisation donc ça ça va me
manquer et puis ensuite c'est ce
sentiment de le privilège de représenter
un peu tout le monde à bord ici d'avoir
cette chance incroyable participer un
peu à d'expansion nos connaissances
ça ça va certainement manquer et puis
l'équipage mes frères et soeurs d'armes
comme on dit on est beaucoup plus proche
que des collègues on est plus proche
même que des amis on est vraiment devenu
un peu une fratrie ça ces gens là vont
marquer cette expérience là c'est
quelque chose qui va toujours rester
alors d'avc jacky rappelé non sans
émotion quels seront les choses qui vont
lui manquer lorsqu'il fut effectuera son
retour sur terre d'ailleurs on approche
au cours des prochaines minutes de son
tout premier contact avec l'atmosphère
il est évidemment hall ces privilégiés
de vivre ça il y en a une autre qui très
privilégié et c'est notre collègue tamar
altéré sco pourquoi elle se trouve au
kazakhstan ce moment dans les steppes
kazakhes tout près des lieux où atterrir
un si tout va comme prévu si tout va
bien
la capsule soyouz à bord de laquelle là
où un des modules de cette capsule à
bord duquel se trouve david saint
jacques et ses deux collègues voyez
l'endroit où ça devrait se dérouler
voyez baïkonour qui est l'endroit à
partir duquel est acquitté david saint
jacques
il ya six mois de ça et ça la zone si on
veut d'atterrissage dans la périphérie
de la localité de gesca se gagnent
voilà tout dit au chaud aussi au sud de
la capitale kazakh c'est dans cet
endroit très aride très plat que va
atterrir la capsule soyouz
éventuellement on va justement voir ce
que nous a fait parvenir à tamar altérer
ce qu il ya quelques minutes à peine on
écoutait ensemble bonsoir à vous mais
bonjour ici parce que c'est tôt le matin
au kazakhstan le soleil s'est levé à il
ya quelques heures et là où on se trouve
c'est vraiment un point qui devenu
historique pour les atterrissages de
l'astre use on est entouré d'un vaste
périmètre dans les steppes du kazakhstan
où il ya 13 points de chute potentiels
qui ont été identifiées pour
l'atterrissage de la cei où ça pourrait
être demain moi derrière moi à ma gauche
à ma droite
tout ça va dépendre du vent il y en a
très peu ce matin comme vous faire
constater les conditions d'atterrissage
sont optimales et le plus beau scénario
je vous dirais c'est qu'elle arrive ici
à quelques mètres seulement de nous et
au moment où je vous parle quand je dis
nous c'est parce que on est entouré
vraiment d'une opération de secours qui
se prépare depuis deux jours à partir du
moment où nous initier au sol on verra
apparaître la skieuse avec son parachute
de 1000 mètres carrés elle sera à 10 km
de la terre c'est à ce moment là que
tous les hélicoptères qui se cachent
dans les steppes iront la rejoindre pour
l'escorter dans les moments dans ses
derniers moments de la descente jusqu'au
sol l'entourent et l'encerclé entrer en
communication avec les astronautes et
une fois qu'elle se pose au sol et bien
tout ce monde-là ira courir à la
rescousse des astronautes ouvrir la
capsule et procéder aux examens médicaux
nécessaires les gens qui nous qui sont
ici avec nous ont vu des dizaines
d'atterrissage dont il ya toujours ce
sentiment d'adrénaline qui anime les
gens on est presque à une demi heure 40
minutes maximum de l'atterrissage est ce
qu'on surveille nous c'est vraiment le
ciel et ceux de voir apparaître une fois
que keller a traversé la la la couche
d'atmosphère ça c'est vraiment la partie
la plus dangereuse la plus intense vous
avez sûrement l'entente de vos experts
quand la capsule fait son entrée dans
les différentes couches de l'atmosphère
terrestre et des températures de 2000
degrés qu'il faudra traverser c'est très
rapide pas pour rien que la la ça use
est protégé par un bouclier thermale une
fois que toute cette étape sera passé
mais nous on attendra de l'avoir ici on
ira
à sa rencontre on a on nous a confirmé
que si tout va bien si tout se passe
comme prévu on pourra parler à david
singer vous savez quand les forces de la
gravité reprennent leurs droits sur ces
hommes et femmes qui ont passé deux cent
huit jours dans le cas de david saint
jacques en apesanteur c'est très violent
c'est très difficile pour le corps
humain il faut s'attendre à voir les
astronautes complètement affaibli
abassourdi certainement par cette
descente assez intense est assez brutal
mais c'est ce sont des hommes qui
récupère assez vite et si tout se passe
comme prévu on pourra parler à david
singer qui aura l'occasion de parler au
téléphone d'abord à sa famille mais son
séjour au kazakhstan sera très très
court une fois qu'il sera examinée par
son médecin il sera menée en hélicoptère
à karaganda qui est à peu près à 500
kilomètres d'ici pour une courte
cérémonie de bienvenue sur terre je vous
dirais et ensuite direction la nasa
c'est là qu'on procédera au cours des
prochaines semaines à tous les examens
médicaux nécessaires pour voir comment
son corps réagit à ce retour sur terre
donc on est sur le qui vive on attend la
confirmation de la nasa de la tour de
contrôle à moscou de toutes ces agences
qui surveille cet atterrissage donc
atterrissage prévu à 22h48 55 secondes
c'est réglé au quart de tour
ça sera quelque part autour de nous dans
les steppes du kazakhstan
donc on essaiera de vous parler un peu
plus tard dans l'émission les parent
communication satellite donc il ya aussi
un black-out médiatique on interrompt
toutes les communications une fois que
la relation ue se pose donc dès qu'on
pourra vous revenir et vous donner des
nouvelles des astronautes
on le fera avec grand plaisir et
regardez bien ça c'est avec grand
plaisir qu'on va vous montrer les toutes
premières images en direct de roskosmos
qu'il agence espaço c'est plutôt l'agent
spatiale canadienne qu'on voit ici en
direct mais on va aussi vous montrer des
images les voici de ce qui se passe dans
le ciel du kazakhstan on a vu passer à
quelques secondes à peine messieurs des
hélicoptères nous tamara
évoquer ces convois d'hélicoptères qui
sont prêts qui patrouille le ciel déjà à
la recherche des premiers signaux de
cette capsule on va voir de quoi dans
les prochaines minutes le premier
parachute n'est ce pas déployer ses
subissent des générations restent leur
poids en ce moment ils sont entourés par
une boule de plasma température de 1806
à peu près avec le bouclier thermique
qui protège des astronautes et très
bientôt ce qui va se produire parce que
si l'atmosphère qui ralentit surtout la
capsule
oui l'atmosphère est un frein
extraordinaire pour cette capsule la met
environ à 10 points 5 km d'altitude
ils seront la capsule sera passée de 28
kilomètres à l'heure quand elle était en
orbite
environ 800 duisans la valeur
décélération de 7,4 on approche du
moment où les parachutes vont sortir
leurs proches du moment d'où
l'importance je tiens la maison ou peu
importe où vous nous écoutez parce que
sachez qu'on est aussi sur facebook live
d'où l'importance de surveiller cette
image on va peut-être voir poindre à
l'horizon
le petit point blanc du du parachute du
premier puisqu'il y en a plusieurs en
tentant de le cherche on cherche en ce
moment les caméras des russes cherchent
ce fameux cet élément-là visuel qui est
très important dans la séquence à
laquelle on assiste en ce moment
poursuivi monsieur hernandez d'allier
dire oui j'allais dire que
on c'est le pire moment effectivement
qui se passe on surnomme le module de
descente aussi la machine à laver
on a l'impression ça bouge dans tous les
sens on est secoué dans tous les sens
mais l'atmosphère est un un précieux
allié pour justement ralentir les
vaisseau spatial et c'est un défi qu'on
aura à relever par exemple quand on ira
sur mars
parce que l'atmosphère de mars est
beaucoup plus ténu et donc pourra moins
ralentir les vaisseaux qui c'est c'est
un dépôt dresse à tel endroit il faudra
s'adapter énormément on voit ici le
paysage la sono pour rien qu'on effectue
ce genre d'atterrissage à cet endroit
extrêmement plat une météo qui plus
clémente qui à cap canaveral n'est ce
pas pas de menace d'ouragans ce genre de
choses a fait est absolument rien puis
c'est très dégagé on peut vraiment avoir
une vue parce qu'on a une précision de
30 km à peu près sûr le l'arrivée
précise de la capsule donc on peut
exactement savoir où elles sont tombées
c'est surtout si on cherche la capsule
depuis depuis les hauteurs avec des
hélicoptères ou des avions en fait comme
c'est le cas actuellement
alors on regarde cette image à l'écran
en un an évidemment c'est très important
de suivre chacun des mouvements qui nous
sont retransmis par les caméras des
russes sur place en vol messieurs
quelques instants de se tourner vers
longueuil et l' agence spatiale
canadienne s'y trouvent
dabi de jean teulé notre collègue ici de
la salle de nouvelles de montréal david
vous êtes là aujourd'hui pour une raison
bien précise david saint jacques
c'est votre ami vous le connaissez
depuis longtemps déjà c'est rare que
vous nous parlez au jeu david mais là
c'est l'occasion et le justifie
l'opportunité le justifie dit non à plus
que vous vivez en sachant que votre ami
david saint-jacques est en train
tranquillement de regagner la terre
écouté beaucoup de fierté évidemment une
certaine appréhension parce que la
manoeuvre reste quand même assez
délicate
j'ai vu sa famille un peu plus tôt là
les gens sont surtout je pense je ne
dirais pas que les gens sont créatifs
je pense que les gens sont plutôt très
content de savoir qu'ils vont pouvoir le
voir le revoir le serrer dans leurs bras
bientôt parce que six mois c'est long
pour moi c'est encore plus long pour les
gens comme sa femme et ses enfants qui
sont séparés depuis depuis très très
longtemps
vous le connaissez et david
saint-jacques vous l'avez côtoyé au fil
des ans david à vide en ce moment même
sachez le on voit l'image
voilà david saint jacques et la capsule
soyouz le module central qui a pénétré
l'atmosphère et qui a déployé son tout
premier parachute le plus gros d'entre
eux alors jusqu'à présent continuer à se
croiser les croisés les droits tout se
passe comme prévu tel que l'ont prévu
les légendes l agence spatiale russe
notamment on voit son entrée is it dans
s'échappe du soyouz sont en train de
purger leurs réservoirs d'oxygène et de
carburant qui sont sous pression pour
que justement il n'y ait pas de risque
d'explosion à l'atterrissage c'est ce
qu'on est en train de voir en ce moment
alors hélas la vitesse comme auditeur
est notablement réduite
tout à fait et on va la mener le plus
bas possible à environ 300 km heure pour
commencer puis ensuite on va larguer le
deuxième parachute et la réduire la
vitesse vraiment le plus le plus bas
possible aux alentours de 25 30 km heure
pour finir à fait avec une feinte
exceptionnel parce que juste au moment
de poser la capsule
on va activer 6 rétrofusées pour pouvoir
perdre le maximum de vitesse avant de
toucher le sol et le fer avec le moins
de dégâts et de dommages possibles
donc il est 22 h 35 heure de l'est je
vous rappelle que c'est vers 22 heures
n'est ce pas 56 et 55 secondes que le
2h15 22 58 et 55 secondes que devrait
s'effectuer le premier contact donc avec
le sol y'a toujours david gillick
étaient les coudes à vis de david
saint-jacques vous le connaissez depuis
bon nombre d'années
d'après ce que vous connaissez de cet
homme exceptionnel qu'est ce qu'il vit
comme émotion en ce moment c'est un type
émotif oui mais c'est aussi quelqu'un
d'extrêmement rationnelle donc je suis
intimement convaincu qu'il utilise son
énorme capacité de concentration pour
justement essayer de rester extrêmement
calme extrêmement lucide de c'est une de
ses grandes forces et je suis convaincu
qu'il s'en sert au maximum actuellement
avec une petite pensée pour ses proches
lui qui va se rendre à houston très
rapidement après avoir touché le sol du
kazakhstan
ouais et puis écoutez moi je ne lui ai
pas parlé depuis quelques semaines
lorsque je parle à david il ya quatre
semaines c'est clair que on commence à
sentir le poids des mois
en d'autres mots ce qui a trait à sa
relation avec ses enfants elle avait
hâte de les voir on sentait que ça ça
grandit sans lui donc absolument certain
que même dans cette descente le point
final qui vient ce moment il commence à
avoir des images justement de ces
premières c'est ses premières étreintes
7,7
ses retrouvailles avec sa famille qu'il
attend sûrement depuis longtemps bah oui
et le retour à une vie normale
il a rêvé d'être astronaute son rêve
s'est réalisé
et là il s'apprête à vivre le moment où
cette parenthèse se referme en tout cas
pour l'instant
david et par la suite pris il vous a
parlé un peu de ce qu'il compte faire
non écoutez là dessus j'ai l'impression
qu'il était très concentré sur sa
mission donc il ne sait pas beaucoup
plus ouvert sur ses projets d'avenir est
ce qu il peut retourner ou non on ne
voulait pas non plus lancer dans ce
genre de questionnement là je dirais pas
que c'était notre travail on voulait que
david demeure concentré donc on sait
justement centre et le tu es fier de
voir à avoir entretenir des
conversations plutôt ludique avec lui
plus que d'essayer de se projeter dans
l'avenir avec david sa tâche dans
l'immédiat quand même on le sait
relativement important c'est le moment
présent qui importe chaque seconde
sa concentration qui est vraiment là
doit être optimale dans ce genre de
situation david zitelli merci beaucoup
d'avoir partagé ces quelques réflexions
sur votre ami et david saint jacques on
vous laisse aller vivre avec les autres
à l'agencé spatiale canadienne ce moment
très important merci encore une fois
david merci bonsoir et merci à voir
alors quand on est ici un studio
vraiment
ça donne des frissons devoir de voir ça
sous nos yeux on est bien content que
vous soyez à la maison et on va
continuer à vous montrer ce en direct en
vous rappelant que tamar altérer ce qu
elle ait lutte au sol en position prêt à
s'approcher du lieu de l'atterrissage
quand on aura une idée précise d'où ça
va se faire elle s'y rendra et son grand
espoir qui le sait et qui est le nôtre
c'est qu'elles puissent par lasser
rapidement david saint-jacques et nous
le faire entendre nous faire entendre sa
voix lui qui avait si hâte de sentir le
vent sur son visage l'air finalement
mais là c'est le fait de renouer avec la
gravité qui doit être très difficile
n'est-ce pas messieurs
mais quand ça fait six mois que tu n'es
pas dans ce puits d'une kavita sionnel
qui est le nôtre sur terre c'est comme
si tu avais été couché pendant six mois
sans élevé alors tes muscles son flat
ghana théo ont été fragilisés ton
système cardiovasculaire est beaucoup
moins performant en plus ton oreille
interne c'est comme déconnecté de la
norges de la neurologie si je puis dire
de ton cerveau pour qu'ils puissent
fonctionner dans l'espace en
microgravité mais quand tu reviens sur
terre il faut qu'elle se reconnecte si
je puis dire ya ce moment là c'est les
nausées c'est les étourdissements et ça
peut prendre des jours voire des
semaines est ce que ça revienne à la
normale
alors on va les voir tout à l'heure on
va bien voir qu'ils ne sont pas en
pleine forme en sortant du soyouz
mais ils sont en santé et ils sont en
sécurité parce que manifestement le
parachute s'est ouvert ça c'était la
dernière exactement c'était la plus
difficile et c'est très rassurant de
voir ces images là c'est rassurant mais
dans quelle mesure on peut se dire ben
voilà c'est pas mal le succès presque
garanti je pense que à partir du moment
où
les choses arrive exactement à l'endroit
où elles doivent arriver les calculs
scientifiques on montre qu' il peut pas
se passer grand chose d'assez dans un
camp un univers une zone beaucoup plus
contrôler exactement contre la b puis la
trajectoire était calculée depuis le
début si on est capable de voir les
capsules avec un parachute lattes
tranquillement descendre un peu comme
une méduse dans l'audace et recel et
bien on peut ne
vraiment se dire qu'il ya aucune crainte
de ce côté là et que tout se passe bien
en fait à bord de la capsule
on va vous montrer au cours des
prochains instant les images de d'autres
atterrissage précédent capsule soyouz
parce que vous décriviez tout à leur
charge
l'état dans lequel se trouvent les
astronautes une fois qu'ils quittent
touche le sol
on vient à eux ils ont peine à marcher
en vo vous montrer ça dans quelques
instants ces images-là et david saint
jacques il eu quoi le le deuxième ou
troisième astronaute canadien à voyager
en capsule soyouz n'est ce pas oui c'est
le troisième 3 3 est ce que je peux
comprendre
d'ailleurs il ya un peu des petits
événements qui vont se produire le
bouclier thermique va être ou a été
largué les déjà été largué il a déjà été
larguée pour que justement les
rétrofusées puisse fonctionner à la base
de la de la capsule et les petites les
petits les petits hublots protecteur qui
sont en verre qui protège les hublots
principaux ont été éjectés également
envoie le moment ici est la maman ou
dans une hausse assez dans une action
précédente
ça c'est quand le parachute le premier
parachuté déployer c'est ce qui vient de
se produire avec david saint jacques et
la capsule soyouz s'était on voit ici un
peu l'animation commence à ces produits
augmentent ces images simplement pour
que vous puissiez vous faire avoir une
idée un peu plus précise et concrète de
ce qui s'est passé on voit la capucine
au moment où le bouclier le bouclier
thermique tombe je vous laisse l'écrire
décrire les images davantage alors qu'on
voit ici à la droite de l'écran ce qui
s'est produit dans une expédition
précédent là on voit les réservoirs qui
sont purgées
on a vu la vapeur et puis la capsule en
principe est un petit peu inclinée
durant la descente pour rafraîchir les
parois ensuite elle se redresse à la
verticale pour pour l'atterrissage
afin de mieux protéger les astronautes
qui d'ailleurs sont dehors des sièges
qui sont sur des amorties sa fille
ouais les aider à absorber ce que
certaines d'entre eux décrivent comme un
accident de voiture
oui un accident une petite auto face à
un gros camion vraiment quelque chose de
désagréable proprement dit ici et on
voit ici l'impact on a pas on n'a pas eu
le temps de voir correctement la fumée
qui se dégage à laisse l'impression que
ça se passe plutôt mal mais c'est normal
c'est les rétrofusées qui s'actionne 60
à 70 cm du sol pour freiner à cinq
kilomètres à l'heure au moment où le
contact se fait lors si ce qui va se
passer avec david saint jacques au cours
des prochaines minutes
alors que je vous le rappelle à la
droite de l'écran ce sont des images
d'archivés vous allez voir sortir de
cette capsule certains donc membre de
l'équipage de l'époque c'était notamment
un italien
l'espace est un belge ou un landais je
prends une des premières choses que le
commandant de la mission va faire après
l'atterrissage s'est décroché l'un des
câbles l'un des deux câbles du parachute
parce que sinon s'il ya trop de vent le
parachute pourrait traîner la capsule
dans les steppes pour empêcher ça dans
décroche un comme ça le parachute
s'affaisse il ne peut pas s'échapper
parce qu'il est encore attaché à la
carie sud ce qui est utile mais la
capsule restent sur place et l'équipe de
secours qui va venir dès que des tâches
et l'autre partie avant de pouvoir
accéder aux astronautes
alors je vous rappelle que ces images
sont en dirait que vous assistez en ce
moment sur nos ondes à la à la descente
finale de la baie de saint jacques au
bout du fil
tamare altéré sco je vous le rappelle
qui va nous parle en direct du
kazakhstan de la steppe qui atteint
l'arrivée de cette capsule soyouz est
sur place si vous allez rapidement vous
rendre vers david saint jacques
bonjour à vous tamraz bonjour à l'excès
on est là il ya quelques minutes on a
entendu fort bien être une énorme
explosion et sas arriver à tout le monde
au sol que ça y est le page très pâle
s'était ouvert et on a pu voir
elle a capella
s'approcher de la série nous au moment
du coup et c'est une course folle de
camiers et que toutes ses conférences et
ses années précisé l'ars précise en fait
l'artiste à l'heure ça dépend des vents
on croise km d'où elle se posera suis
donc c'est un peu à ça que ça ressemble
hélas on va voir les hélicoptères
bientôt le supporter pour sa descente
finale il reste quelques buts et il ya
le walkie talkie avec la voiture on a
accès ce que sous-entend du haut
koenigsbourg reconnaît elle
il est alors vous l'équipe de secours
allaient retrouver sur le terrain d'ici
là on voit on en est pour le moment elle
est tout aussi nous on la voit les
parachutés dans les hélicoptères l'enfer
pour aller l'accompagner dans sa défense
final le seul mystère en ce moment c'est
savoir où exactement
elle va se poser on y sera pour vous
apporter en direct j'espère pouvoir
faire un peu plus tard on aura accès
avait déjà qu une fois la fille n'est
pas évident qu'ils vivent mieux la
descente que d'autres amis et toute
façon on pourra lui parler dans la
lumière qui puis ah ben ça c'est ce
qu'on souhaite c'est ce qu'on souhaite
tous ici et ailleurs il ya beaucoup de
gens qui attendent ce moment avec
impatience que ce soit à houston au
kazakhstan à montréal évidemment alors
dès que vous avez vous êtes bien de ce
moment fatidique faites nous signe quand
je vous écoute poursuiv ait pu faire on
à nous et à l'oeil nu comme ça fait
quelques kilomètres mais encore une fois
pas pourquoi il ya très peu de vent
les pouvoirs finale qu'on appelle un
sport landais en anglais mais qu'une
rien de sport du conseil du mois
c'est assez brutal peut-être aussi
brutale de ce qu'ils viennent de vivre
en entrant dans l'atmosphère terrestre
les sai est elle se repose de nous on la
voit très bien on voit maintenant la
clape une parachute rose et qui sait nos
envies nous on a des indications très
précises pour ne pas nuire aux travaux
de secours donc aller au moment où sont
venues se recueillent aussi farfelue
radioactives hillman de ses rétros fusée
qui ralentissent de choses donc offrant
à quelques mètres de la fusée au moment
de la sortie très bien à plus tard
tamarins et on est bien de vous entendre
avec espérons-le à vos côtés david saint
jacques ce sera surveillé sur les ondes
du cirdi a plus tard tamarins alors
voilà pour tamara évidemment la
communication est pas toujours facile
vous le comprendrez dans les
circonstances où dans le contexte dans
lequel se trouve ça marrant on peut une
steppe du kazakhstan envoyé au bas de
l'écran à gauche c'est la scène à
laquelle on assiste à l'intérieur même
de l'agencé spatiale canadienne imaginer
la fébrilité des gens sur place
les proches des amis d'aix astronautes
canadiens alors il est 22 heures 47
messieurs ici en studio ça arrive ça
arrive
ils vont se mettre dans la configuration
corporelle nécessaire pour
l'atterrissage
ils vont se recroqueviller comme ça ils
vont faire attention de ne pas parler
pour ne pas se mordre la langue
et puis ils vont se contracter ils sont
dans des sièges parfaitement prévu pour
eux afin de mieux absorber le choc de
l'arrivée ils travaillent dans quelques
secondes
on devrait pas tarder à voir donc être
au fise est ce nom et en actions voilà
le moment on voit le sol terrestre et
c'est fait voilà c'est un petit peu loin
là on a peu loin on voit la fumée or
voilà fait voilà c'est voilà bravo bravo
mais sur laquelle mission accomplie pour
david saint-jacques 49 ans je vous le
rappelle qui oui c'est mission accomplie
et un rêve qui la réalise
c est de toute évidence tout s'est bien
passé on peut donc croire que la vie de
saint jacques et a écarté toute forme de
souci reste à voir dans quel état
physique n'est ce pas il va être
imaginer la joie de son épouse en ce
moment qui se trouve à houston de ses
trois enfants qui l'accompagnent et qui
ont qu'ils l'ont accompagnée tout au
long de ce périple de 6000 pense à tous
ces milliers d'étudiants et des colliers
à qui il a parlé en cours de mission de
ses 204 jours de mission jacques ses
charges extraordinaires sans une
certaine émotion quand même j'ai les
boules mais c'était de le le fait qu'il
ait parlé à tous ses étudiants la pila
et et pédagogue il leur a expliqué
comment une goutte d'eau se se se
comporte dans l'espace comment on mange
dans l'espace commandant dans l'espace
comment s'entraînent dans l'espace
c'était fantastique et il avait des
expériences avec des jeunes qu'il
réussissait à mener de là-haut
régulièrement part de centaines et de
centaines de jeunes par trou à travers
le canada de noix de nas talhouët
chusclan grenat c'est remarquable
hélas pour lui d'abord c'était le monde
et dans une grange ou envoient les
hélicoptères russes qui s'approche du
lieu de l'atterrissage ya pas que des
hélicoptères et des véhicules tout
terrain dans une ses véhicules tout
terrain se trouve tamar altéré squat y
ont parlé à quelques instants l'hiver
nantaise là encore une fois c'est une
opération hautement chorégraphie dans le
faitout tout est chorégraphié du début
jusqu'à la fin chacun sait exactement ce
qu'il doit faire des cosmonautes
jusqu'au au personnel qui va s'occuper
de sa sécurité au complet donc là tout
le monde se précipite sur le lieu pour
pouvoir les extraire le plus rapidement
possible quand même de la capsule
et puis avoir le contact visuel avec eux
et et partager cette émotion là
c'est vraiment un moment très très
émotif la de le voir descendre et et je
suis sûr que l'on connaît david
saint-jacques et c'est quelqu'un de tout
à fait exceptionnel qui est capable de
retransmettre son émotion c'est pour ça
qu'il a beaucoup de succès d'ailleurs
c'est un communicateur c'est un
communicateur hors pair et c'est
vraiment fantastique de le connaître de
l'approché d'une générosité incroyable
et c'est fantastique c'est vraiment
quelqu'un d'exception oui et une
personne qui étaient tout à fait
conscientes n'est ce pas des risques
qu'ils encouraient pour sa santé a pas
de mystère la tuile le sait très bien
médecin qu'il les attendait
l'entraînement qu'il a eu il le sait
bien qu'il y aura des séquelles à tout
jamais de ce périple de quoi de plus de
200 jours à 400 kilomètres au dessus de
nos têtes alors qu'on voit ici les
hélicoptères qui se sont posée dans les
steppes kazakhes
sous un ciel presque presque entièrement
dépouillé de nuage en ce qui a facilité
peut-être sûrement son arrivée est là
parce que ce qu'il faut rappeler c'est
qu'ils arrivent sur place
oui une manoeuvre qui ce qui s'enclenche
mais assez rapidement ils se quittent
vers houston des mamans faty la demande
et pourquoi si rappelez il est sous
surveillance médicale à partir du moment
où ils ouvrent l'écoutille de la delà du
soyouz il est vu par des médecins tout
de suite il va dans une tente à côté
avec les autres on examine on s'assure
que ses signes vitaux sont stables qu'il
est correct et là il prends
l'hélicoptère pendant deux heures
jusqu'à l'aéroport de repos pas de repos
et de l'aïe prend l'avion vers houston
avec une équipe médicale à bord et en
arrivant il va il va subir tous les
tests d'abord pour s'assurer qu'il est
en forme que ça va que sa santé est
bonne mais aussi poursuivre les
expériences auxquelles il a participé
dans la station spatiale
il faut l'examiner tout de suite dès son
arrivée pour voir si 6 cellules
sanguines ont été modifiés ces globules
blancs
comment se comporte son coeur et son
système cardio vasculaires etc et
ensuite il va suivre pendant des
semaines et des semaines trois semaines
en fait d'entraînement rigoureux pour
reprendre une forme minimale mais ça va
prendre six mois pour sa réadaptation
soit à peu près terminions dit une
journée dans l'espace pour une journée
dans l'espace
il faut une journée de réévaluation sur
terre à bord d'un str nôtres qui sont
allés dans la
de faire mon pote au dessus de la
parenthèse un enseignant et on ne sait
pas tout à fait en fait exactement ce
qui se passe après on sait qu'il ya des
pertes de densité osseuse on sait que la
structure osseuse et modifier aussi et
on ya beaucoup d' études qui sont menées
justement sur les astronautes on n'a pas
encore suffisamment de recul pour savoir
et que pour avoir des résultats
d'expériences alors ça ça prend
plusieurs astronautes pour pouvoir avoir
un bassin statistiques suffisamment
important on y reviendra d'ailleurs
messieurs sur les expériences qu'il a
réalisés en cours en cours de périple en
orbite autour de la terre
parce que tout seul nous prépare vers
une éventuelle mission sur mars est
important de le rappeler
on va se quitter le temps d'une courte
pause on vous rappelle que david saint
jacques s'est posé sur le sol terrestre
tout s'est bien passé en tout cas en
apparence on est en train de se diriger
en ce moment vers le lieu précis de
l'atterrissage tamar altérer ce coup je
vous le rappelle notre collègue envoyé
spécial est sur place on espère bien que
tamara pour s'entretenir avec david
saint-jacques et par le fait même nous
le faire entendre pour la toute première
fois on voit l'entendre depuis son
retour et qui vient tout juste de
s'effectuer sur l'espace terrestre alors
courte pause restait l'un en suisse en
direct pour vous pour cet été avec cette
émission spéciale sur le retour de david
saint-jacques a tout de suite
[Musique]
bienvenue à cette émission spéciale
consacrée au retour sur terre de david
saint-jacques opération réussie il est
de retour parmi nous tout s'est bien
passé à 22h46 très près sims précisé
précisément du bien c'est le moment
auquel cette capsule soyouz a touché le
sol terrestre sans embûche sans
anicroche sans pépin et on est très
content de le voir et de le constater on
va vous remonterez ces images auxquelles
qu'on veut présenter un peu plus tôt il
ya quelques minutes à peine voyez le
moment ici il ya eu le déploiement de
cette de ce parachute une dizaine de
kilomètres l'ath ii du sol et voilà
quand il s'est posé cette fumée qui est
tout à fait normal n'est pas
nécessairement le fruit du contact
direct entre la capsule est le seul mais
bien aussi le fruit de ces fusées n'est
ce pas qui amortissent il a manqué de
fuser oui ces derniers feraient le
dernier frein avant cette étape ultime
qui est qui a été franchi
peut-être d'ailleurs ça c'est assez
marrant sur ces fusées il ya une
anecdote tout à fait croustillantes
c'est que ces fusées là qui détermine la
durée de vie de la de la capsule soyouz
en orbite et parce qu'elles sont faites
le carburant qu'elles possèdent ces du
peroxyde d'hydrogène qui qui fuit
légèrement en fait et au bout de six
mois il n'est plus aussi puissant que
que l'on aimerait et ça pourrait mettre
en danger le retour sur terre des
astronautes alors la durée de vie d'une
capsule dépend uniquement de 7,2 cette
petite rétrofusées qui sont
fondamentales parce qu'elle amortissent
lixon le dernier amortisseur avant
d'arriver sur terre et ils ont rajouté
deux avant le savez les quatre et il ya
quelques temps ils ont leur ajouter deux
probablement parce que les astronautes
non russe russe pets et rots avant ils
trouvaient que le shaq était un petit
peu trop brutale et ça c'est brit est si
je puis dire partout à travers le monde
avoue présumer que les russes sont du
moment voir un jour on va rajouter de la
peur que ça ralentissait encore impute
un petit peu plus ouais mais à mes
gamins loi le rappelle c'est important
les russes et quand on regarde leur fais
chier on veut elle est plutôt bonne
les choses se déroulent très bien pour
les russes depuis des décennies et des
décennies avec la capsule
si vous vous l'avez dans l'espace prenez
soin use vraiment c'est ce qu'avait fait
le seul et unique touristes tout à fait
canadiens qui étaient dans l'espace du
réalisateur guy laliberté station
spatiale internationale or ce qui se
passe en ce moment alors qu'on voit on
revoit ses images c'est que les équipes
on présume qu elles sont arrivées sur
place aux abords de la capsule
des hélicoptères des véhicules tout
terrain ni équipe médicale est bien
entendu on va accueillir les les
astronautes et et le cosmonaute qui se
trouvent le commandant monsieur kone le
court et là ce sera l'ouverture n'est ce
pas de l'écoutille oui il s'ouvre assez
facilement d'ailleurs pour que justement
si elle devait atterrir très très loin
de la cible et que des gens dans le
secteur trouve la capsule qu'ils
puissent l'ouvrir avant les indications
qui s'efface il assez facile à ouvrir
c'est pas ça se fait pas comme ça mais
même quelqu'un qui n'aurait pas été
formés serait capable d'ouvrir
l'écoutille à condition de lire le russe
s'est aussi recueilli ce serait
effectivement oui effectivement
et pour la suite imaginez la joie en ce
moment et à houston et longueuil l'agent
spécial canadienne est aussi à la
station spatiale internationale qui
vient d'ailleurs on vient de gazouiller
de d'envoyer un tweet depuis la station
spatiale internationale en disant
touchdown
mission accomplie par scania qui sont
restés là c'est important de le rappeler
mais où il ya eu la cérémonie hier n'est
ce pas de la passation des clés des
commandes de la station spatiale
internationale
alors à partir de la bande de la ou si
on observait david saint jacques
nick clegg est encore là alexis vichy
nine qui est maintenant le commandant de
bord et puis christina quoique et là
également et ce qui est ce qui est
formidable pour le programme canadien
d'exploration spatiale pour pas
l'oublier c'est que david saint jacques
s'est retrouvé dans cette station là ils
étaient seulement 3 il aurait dû être un
ils étaient trois c'est parce qu'il ya
eu cet incident à d'octobre il ya deux
astronautes qui n'ont pas pu se rendre à
la station
dieu merci qui ont eu la vie sauve mais
les astronautes qui ont pu se rendre de
3 décembre
rapidement ce qui était déjà là sont
revenus sur terre et se retrouver ils
sont plusieurs mois ils sont trois mois
trois mois seul et donc ils avaient des
expériences scientifiques à faire et il
avait une autre tiers de l'insertion
aussi et ils ont réussi à le faire et
david saint-jacques a probablement ainsi
que l ukraine ils ont probablement fait
le travail de trois astronautes
et on dit que ça a permis à david
saint-jacques de si on veut de faire
augmenter ses chances d'effectuer une
sortie n'est ce pas à l'intérieur de la
station spatiale internationale
probablement probablement quoique
beaucoup de choses sont déjà à cannes et
en fait ouais à l'origine je pense que
la sortie était déjà privé objet office
donc géré à peut-être été plus lent mais
elle aurait peut-être été plus longue
j'accomplis oui probablement où elle a
peut-être été devancé
mais mimi l'éclair que le
c'est un succès complet cette mission là
surtout pour l'agencé spatiale
canadienne la réputation du canada du
spatial du domaine spatial du canada ici
est vraiment sorti grandi et ça laisse
présager beaucoup de bonnes choses en
fait pour la suite parce qu'on va on va
pouvoir faire confiance aux canadiens
leur expertise est vraiment très
intéressante les qualités des
astronautes canadiens sont et de toute
l'équipe qui est au sol bien sûr etc
l'agent spécial est vraiment très très
alors qu'on voit ici les images du 8
avril dernier n'est ce pas charles on
l'avait commentée ensemble à ce moment
là en direct c'est la sortie de david
saint jacques en dehors de la station
spatiale internationale à mme mcclean
aussi n'est ce pas elle est sortie avec
lui ces moments périlleux quand même
parce que tu n'es plus protégés par la
carlingue de la station spatiale tu es
dans ton vaisseau spatial autonome et 11
cas fin je crois quand on va on va être
messieurs il ya des images qui nous
proviennent de la russie de la capsule
elle même les ingénieurs qui s'y
trouvent décrivez-nous un peu ce qui se
passe en ce moment
charles et monsieur hollandaise là ils
ont installé une structure par dessus
pour justement pouvoir aider les
astronautes à sortir par les couty ils
vont l'astronaute va s'asseoir sur cette
structure là ils vont l'aider à
descendre et ils vont le transporter
jusqu'à vraiment une chaise longue
près de là tout près du soyouz la
préparons nos avants david saint-jacques
sortir sachez qu'il fait au delà de 35
degrés en ce moment au kazakhstan
évidemment c'est rien pour david saint
jean qui vient de traverser des
températures de 2 degrés mais quand même
on a bien a tous hâte de le voir de voir
là si on veut son allure son visage dans
quel état il est physiquement un peu on
peut le présumer qu'une énergie un peu
moins grande qu'on l'a vu quelques jours
à peine alors qu'ils communiquent encore
toujours avec la terre avec cette même
passion cette même fougue voyez à
quantité de gens présents autour et
sachets catamar altéré secouent notre
collègue qui dans les environs son micro
et pressent caméraman aussi on espère
qu'elle pourra parler david saint
jacques
ce qui est remarquable alexis c'est de
voir jusqu'à quel point et avec quelle
vitesse les secouristes ont réussi à
rejoindre la capsule installer cette
structure là pour aider les astronautes
à sortir c'est vraiment remarquable
si vous dire jusqu'à quel point ils ont
bien planifier la trajectoire depuis des
jours et des jours avec le centre de
contrôle en russie et comment dans le
fond les ordinateurs de bord et les
rétrofusées ont bien contrôlé sa rentrée
dans la manoeuvre pour 46 ans est le
premier à on essaie de voir est ce que
si monsieur kone lenco oui mais que
l'amérique leur chapeau alors madame est
clean donc cette américaine qui était
ingénieur de vol des sports garder son
visage qui souriante elle est souriante
mais quand même la lumière j'imagine
s'était fait de la gravité d'abord et
surtout c'est important de rappeler un
indécent intercity soir oui c'est
vraiment comme à l'aéroport enfin
baisser du fait des séances spéciales et
nous c'est monsieur konan inco je crois
est ce que comme officiel
à voir mais je crois qu'ils aient le
commandant monsieur cassé sa position
dans la capsule qui probablement
commande ça parce que il est au centre
alors comment ce que les autres peuvent
sortir facilement si lui n'est pas sorti
exactement dont c'est probablement la
raison pour laquelle c'est lui qui est
sorti d'abord mais je connais nico donc
était commandant de cette de cette
capsule pour le retour david saint
jacques on était le co pilote est ce que
ça se traduit donc le deuxième par ordre
si on veut plus ou moins hiérarchique
qui va sortir de la capsule et ça reste
à voir
ça va se savoir au cours des prochaines
sorties on voit son drapeau en fait
russe sur son sort son badge aux
valeureux le voit ici n'est ce pas ce
que vous décrivez un peu plus tôt
charles en s'occupent les soins médicaux
les premiers soins médicaux l'union
prodigue il oui on veut vérifier encore
une fois que leurs signes vitaux sont
stables qui sont somme toute en dépit de
tout la correcte et on y transférera un
petit peu plus loin dans une tente où
des examens petit peu plus approfondis
seront enfin avant qu'ils soient
transportés vers leurs avions respectifs
qui dans le cas de monsieur de monsieur
qu naumenko la mènera tout près de
moscou et dans le cas des de
l'astronaute américaine et de david
saint jacques vers houston
la scène est tellement différent moi ça
me frappe entre les la façon de procéder
des russes et des américains retour
comme ça c'était une façon la différence
vient essentiellement aux sites que le
véhicule n'est pas le même et la durée
des vols avec mon américains étaient
très limitées aussi donc à quelques
dizaine de jours à peu près lorsqu'il
volait sur la navette spatiale et donc
les effets de l'apesanteur était moins
ressenti est on
ea semble envoyer les américains
capables de marcher en sortant de la
navette spatiale
beaucoup plus simplement que après avoir
passé six mois dans l'espace donc la
différence vient essentiellement de là
et c'était ça surprend peut-être de
l'étang somme toute assez je n'avais pas
impeccable en tout cas la capsule elle
même n'a pas l'air nécessairement donc
affectés par le choc du gelato on ne la
voit pas beaucoup on voit que sa couleur
a légèrement changé en fait
était légèrement carbonisé en fait à
cause des hautes températures
probablement on voit pas le bas de la
capsule
sur ces images là ont probablement que
l'impact a quand même endommagé une
partie de la capsule c'est sûr que cette
capsule la norme entrera pas du tout
dans l'espace
on me dit que j'ai quant à marc à
altérer ce cobra fils je voulais amarré
sur place elle est tout près de la
capsule en vous écoute ta main en
espérant que la communication sera bonne
le capitaine sa cinquième mission
je voudrais qu'il est libre comme un
drame sourit et on procède à des examens
médicaux son coup on hydrate et là on
attend impatiemment de voir qui sera le
deuxième phase a fort bien sûr admet
klein l'a mérité nous avaient pas
jacques ça dépend du mouvement qu'il ya
eu dans la capsule meilleur les trois
sont sains et saufs ils ont pu
communiquer avec les gens à l'extérieur
il ya 200 personnes à peu près un gros
coup de grenades
beaucoup de gens de l'agencé spatiale
russe roskosmos et des représentants de
la gent spéciales canadiennes et ça y
est on tend la main à l'intérieur et on
s'apprête à sortir le deuxième alors que
l'autre est ce que ça sera de l'état
jacques on sera dans quelques secondes
voilà vous avez l'image etc et anne
claire sur la fin tout le monde à claude
louis allard à l'enfant à la forme avec
la voix elle même
les femmes sont plus et elle est très
excitée c'est sa première mi temps voilà
en la glisse vers le sol et nous on et
voyez où il ya la glissade tapis blouson
les juste devant le tas tout bleu devant
les chagos on longe le temps de
récupérer tout le monde silence radio à
un moment clé ce produit comme celui
qu'on vit en ce moment et après les gens
à poser c'est des gens ici qui ont les
crimes qui ont l'expérience de ces
atterrissages annakin ont vu une
cinquantaine mais il est toujours fait
même plus fort y est voilà on la
transporte allongé en sueur mais elle
est bonne couleur elle sourit à parle à
son médecin et vous voyez parmi les
médecins et un médecin canadien lloris
et le médecin ainsi pardon je descendais
à des singes a donc lui va vite retourné
à la fouillouse pour s'occuper de
principal intéressé banque de données
pour les as qui sera le prochain
on attend sais pas combien ça prend de
temps exactement les sortir ça dépend de
leur position pour les failles a pas de
mouvement ou plus a few des trois
secouristes
ils attendent qu'on leur donne le feu
vert pour sortir le troisième chrono et
certains se demandent quels sont les
instructions qu'on vous donne à vous sur
le moment à partir duquel vous allez
pouvoir par la dame et saint jacques ont
tous l'attendent
j'avais envie j'ai l'habitude d'avoir
accès à absolument rien c'est étonnant
la liberté avec laquelle on peut
circuler autour d'artistes avoir les
minuscules et les câliner et là la
partie dangereuse donc l'émanation de
radio de france à toi aussi déterminé on
est proche de toute façon l'état elle a
atterri à la verticale c'est le scénario
idéal donc on est absolument aucune
restriction ne veut plus de ces cordons
de place et que vous savez ce qu'on met
autour des scènes de crime qui nous
sépare des astronomes mais c'est des
chaises d'échelle soleil comme on peut
en acheter chez chez cosco c'est
vraiment rare jobing com passion c'est
vraiment très simple c'est un peu ça qui
fait la beauté si vous voulez de ces
opérations de secours même du décollage
c'est très simple
a très peu changé dans les façons de
faire depuis l'union soviétique était
bourré de tradition ici les gens dans
les steppes en général tout ce qui
entoure l'atterrissage et le décollage
c'est bourré traduction en trinquet la
vodka en train coverity de ces occasions
sont bonnes même dans les steppes
tractant on a sorti les corniches on a
sorti les échalotes et c'est pas une
caricature que je vous fais là c'est
vraiment la façon dont on le vit depuis
depuis deux jours près l'andorre où les
vuvuzelas 500 km 10 heures à peu près
dans les stades pour arriver ici on a pu
glisser tradition voilà on se parle on a
vu bien monsieur konan enhco parler au
téléphone peut être avec des proches
vous êtes tout juste à côté de ces
astronautes et qui viennent de revenir
dans la normalité si on veut terrestre
alors qu'on s'apprête comme vous le
dites à peu à sortir extirper de cette
capsule david saint jacques
tamara oui et monsieur connaît un coup
par la femme je peux vous le confirmer
le premier rappelle qu'ils font tous
appeler leurs proches des transferts cpt
le fera aussi sa femme et politiciens
que justement on est venu où l'enfant
avec nous elle était là avec les trois
enfants mais cette fois-ci j'attendais
hewson parce que son séjour ici que 500
avec très très court
quand vous allez le voir apparaître qui
va passer une heure et demie après dans
une tente médicale tout au plus et après
on le transporte en hélicoptère à la
l'hérault à l'aéroport de karaganda où
une cérémonie très typique où on leur
offre même des matriochkas à l'éffigie
de chaque cosmonaute et ensuite il part
avec sa collègue micheline pour la nasa
pour houston c'est son port d'attache
c'est ça qu'on veut leur a passé le plus
vite possible pour exercer qui mené tous
les examens ni nico ils suivent ikea à
faire après
le jour où on en a besoin car je vous
rappelle que pour un canadien c'est pas
le plus long de l'histoire pour un
astronome et pour un canal un jour un an
c'est un record on n'avait pas assez 206
j'ai peur de me tromper dans les chips
quelqu'un peut vous corriger mais
techniquement oui c'est le plus haut en
six jours dans l'espace et voilà je
crois qu'on va les sortir les volumes et
les prix des secours
on va devoir alors que monsieur colenco
s'hydratent un peu et on le comprend
bien les caméras pour l'instant sont
braqués sur monsieur kone nico mais pour
nous décrire la scène si jamais vous
êtes en mesure de voir david saint
jacques
on voit ici une sphère allez-y il est
bien de le ville pour eux celui mais
tous semblent tout en devient face et
régler au moment où on parlait les
rapatrier au sol très pâle mécontents de
toute évidence on nous dit qu'il ya un
malaise les céréales gras était
complètement normal encore une fois
imaginé les forces et gravité voilà il
est devant nous on veut laisser
récupérer à l'installer sur la scène du
détour ya et voilà je dirais que oui on
les reçoit et j'en reviens pas du fait
que vous êtes si près tamarac david
saint-jacques à quelle distance êtes
vous de lui en ce moment
et bien honnêtement on pourrait lui
marqué des questions mais avec le
respect qu'on lui doit on va attendre
on va attendre qu'ils nous donnent le
pousse la confirmation qu'il est prêt à
nous parler et cette fois pas le cas et
c'est pas le cas maintenant sur la
chaîne en or à la fin de lui parler une
fois que tu as sorti de la tente
médicale don krieg raté alors retrouvé
ses esprits mais pour l'instant il
semble bien aimer pour une fois bien
dans les circonstances
oui alors que son médecin est en train
de lui prodiguer les premiers soins
on le voit envoyer encore monsieur kone
nico sur les images qui nous parviennent
en direct et tamara vous finalement vous
boucler la boucle puisque vous l'avez vu
partir vous l'avez
à tout juste avant son départ et vous
les assistez vraiment premières loges à
son arrivée sur terre est-ce qu'il a
déjà prononcé quelques paroles que ce
que vous voyez dans le visage de david
saint jacques au complet c'est normal
encore une fois il ya pas lieu de
s'inquiéter
je pense à ses proches qui nous écoutent
ya pas lieu de s'inquiéter c'est c'est
extrêmement violent sur le système et
chaque astronaute réagit différemment on
nous a prévenus ça pourrait être le cas
il ya des fois il y en a qui perdent
connaissance carrément c'est pas le cas
il est bien assis il est lié le dos
droit mais il a un malaise en france au
plus fort le réhydrater célèbre série
quand ils traversent l'atmosphère il
vise les températures absolument
épouvantable ces colons mais c'est très
violent sur le corps et pour l'instant
il ya trois quatre cinq six sept
personnes autour de 8,2 l'agent spatiale
russe mais le projet celui qui l'a vu
frotter le dos au moment où on se parle
et à l'encourager c'est bien sûr son
effet raffy qui venus de montréal pour
assister à ce moment et la compagnie
dans les prochaines minutes sont
difficiles
pas pour rien que vous voyez des gens
cachés david saint jacques c'est qu'il a
des il se sent pas bien et façades
europe où l'on taille c'est complètement
normal non autour ça y est la capsule
est vide on va là on voit là la retirer
or et nous on va laisser le hasard que
récupérer exane
alors ici alors qu'on voit ici la
commande à monsieur cholodenko qui
viennent croquer à belles dents dans une
pomme ça a l'air épuisé tout simplement
manger ou hockey dans une pomme pour
monsieur koné dit qu il garde son prénom
il en est à sa cinquième mission pour
l'un des césar qui est une première mais
encore une fois c'est pas nécessairement
une question d'expérience est question
de système ça car il fait différemment
j'ai complètement bloquer la vue à
monsieur saint jacques ont convenu de
donner un peu d'eux le temps de
remercier en privé par les opéras et
moules et on se doit de respecter ça
imaginez le trajet qu'il vient de subir
descente infernale
c'est très violent on les secousses
ressenties voire de tous genres tarder
le pire manège dans un parc d'amusement
va exposer en nul c'est comme ça qu'il a
décrit donc et à vis de ces jeunes vous
en avez parlé n'est ce pas avant son
départ de ce moment qu'il allait vivre
celui du retour sur terre il était tout
à fait conscient de tous les dangers que
ça comprenez pour l'huile puis on
s'entend crée t décollage parfait moi
j'ai vu ça a été parfait un atterrissage
parfait a coûté 11 ans a mis dix minutes
à arriver aussi donc libre la capsule tu
es vraiment qu'on est là où elle devait
se poser à la verticale car elle est à
l'horizontale c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué dans l'expertisé les
astronautes dont tout s'est passé au
quart de tour exactement comme prévu
et ça sera le cas pour son retour sur
terre aussi son métal viennent de l'eau
alors on idrac s'est toujours seul le
plus grand problème on hydrate on lui
parle il a pas encore un téléphone dans
la main escada mclean madame est clean
qu'à ce moment est en train de parler à
ses proches
d'où ce sourire ce soulagement j'imagine
au o2 boula de la conversation
oui c'est la plus jeune à bord de la
capsule
je vais parler avant décollage il ya six
mois et demi elle était tellement
excitée elle est maman en plus donc de
revoir les enfants de revoir confié à
l'appel des haines cuites et souvent
pour les avis pour les les occasions
qu'il a manquées pour noël et s'en est
passé des choses depuis divers lycées
ont repris avec elle a manqué que la
vaisselle a commenté ce qu'ils disaient
david saint jacques ce qu'ils
appréhendaient tellement le retour avec
les forces de gravité que le verbe dans
la piscine parce que c'est là qu'ils
vont pouvoir retrouver cette aide de ne
plus sentir son poids mais c'est encore
une fois il a l'air quand même besoin ou
le lever le pouce
il est assis donc tout indique qu une
question de quelques minutes ou quelques
heures avant qu'il retrouve le sourire
et en plus se déplacer vers la sphère
médicale d'ailleurs l'un à gauche parce
que vous voyez sur le transport
je transporte vers la tente
mais du calme pour marcher il y en a qui
réussissent mais c'est très très très
rare il sent pas l'argent cécile et
d'une jambe c'est comme si on enlevait
une jambe il force le boulet la
prochaine sera allumé clé alors là je
vois de ledger qui sourit parle à son
médecin semble prendre un peu de mieux
et en plus puisque vous confirmé s'être
enfui de griffes bien aujourd'hui alors
nous faut voir des combinaisons
spatiales
on lui il a une casquette sur la tête
pour le protéger du soleil il est assis
il a dù courbée vers l'avant donc ils se
seraient pleines humaine n'est pas
allongé mais la valette les manèges et
nettement une arrivée un peu plus
difficile en tout cas c'est tel qu'en
témoigne et les images que ses deux
coéquipiers
madame mclean qu'on va dans un tout
autre état d ordre physique et d'esprit
je ne sais pas mais physiquement elle a
l'air d'aller tout à fait bien six que
le vétéran monsieur kone une coque on
peut voir ici alors qu'il pénètre dans
que c'est tantôt elle les soins médicaux
un peu plus poussées comme nous
l'expliqué charles seront prodigués donc
à celui qui aura été le commandant
jusqu'au retour on procède au même
manège ici avec madame mclean qui est
soulevé évidemment dans cette incapacité
qu'elle a de marché et qui elle aussi
subir à plus ou moins les mêmes
traitements alors que monsieur saint
jacques mais on attend toujours une
image plus claire de ce qui se passe là
on le voit ici depuis la caméra se
concentre un peu plus sur lui ou son
entourage à tout le moins comme on le
dit ferme les yeux il était tout
revisité vomir parce qu'ils avaient
jetée vraiment des gens qui ont
l'expérience et qui l'aide à composer
avec ces premières minutes au sol
poursuit ce sacré coup surtout pas
s'inquiéter de l'état dans lequel il est
au moment où je parle c'est en haussant
normal on prend 5 où on lui tient la
main et on lui donne des conseils pour
pour se sentir mieux parce que
ça va être des moments et qu'il travers
pudiquement qui motive mais on n'en
parle même pas ça doit être encore les
uns qui sont isolées moi qui déteste et
sa réticence à faire était en national
depuis six mois et demi là il se
retrouve avec 203 soleil plombant l'air
frais un peu de goût plus ou moins
radicales ne sont pas des ailes que je
vous décris mais c'est la vie c'est
comme ceux qui la vit en ce moment mais
pour l'instant on continue de protéger
physiquement et le cachet de la vue des
caméras pour justement lui donner c'est
le moment pour retrouver un certain
niveau de confort avant qu'on puisse que
l'udc l'a fait voilà ici s'y était
préparé quand même au centre de
formation et youri gagarine avant son
départ mais quand même quand on lui
c'est autre chose
d'où la nécessité d'avoir des gens
d'expérience autour de choix alors que
je le rappelle à houston iah véronique
morin son épouse pierre léon et sophie
ses trois enfants qui vivent ces moments
tout comme nous avec un niveau un peu
plus élevé peut-être de fébrilité et on
le comprend bien tu as maltais est ce
que vous avez rencontré d'ailleurs sa
famille au moment du départ du oui alors
je confirme que ça on a pris quatre ans
après son tranquille alors faire un
business à 85
vous avez compris donc est bon jeudi
reprend ça vaille ont envie de nous
positionner devant lui donc on a
l'impression qu'on pourrait nous donner
bientôt le feu vert mais encore une fois
j'ai presque envie de parler pour le
moment et lui donner ces minutes à lui
est l'occasion de parler à sa blessure
avant soldes caméra avant d'adresser aux
médias donc on aura fait sur laquelle on
lui parlait il ya trois ou quatre ans
durant lesquels ont pu le faire quand il
sera transporté à la tante quand il en
sortira probablement en marchant il en a
la capacité voilà on le détail on lui
donne on lui permet de s'aérer plus on
détache la conduite comme les gens
s'installent et il est vraiment encerclé
c'est quand même beau avoir cette
solidarité les astronautes
tout le monde est autour de lui
monde encourage hôtel à main tremble
plus mais encore une fois je défends ton
complètement normal nous on coud cet
atterrissage nous arrivons 8 ans ou sept
ans ça se voit qu'ils les six mois
toutes les années ici dans les steppes
kazakhes temps de façon à l'hiver comme
l'été ne fore un astronaute qui réagit
de la même façon quand les forces de la
gravité reprennent leurs droits comme il
est bien évidemment david saint-jacques
et un médecin lui-même il est tout à
fait conscient de ce qui se passe dans
son corps des deux la nécessité des
soins qu'on lui prodigue convoi je le
note ici pour vous une aux
téléspectateurs au bas de l'écran à
gauche c'est l'image qui nous provient
direct de l' agence spatiale canadienne
les gens sont en attente tout comme nous
d'en savoir un peu plus sur david
saint-jacques et aussi de le voir de le
voir en eux cette nécessité de ne voir
on le très brièvement aperçue au moment
de sa sortie et très rapidement tamara
vous nous avez informé qu'il est
subissaient ou qu'il était aux prises
avec un malaise ça semble se résorber
tranquillement mais pour l'instant on
n'a pas accès à cette image que nous
donnait tout à l'heure la caméra d re ce
qui se trouve sur place tout comme vous
d'ailleurs qui est aux premières loges
beaucoup de journalistes ce moment
non ici et c'était un déplacement assez
exceptionnel n'y a pas de journalistes
et documentaristes savez ces gens qui
sont cool est fausse
et puis je dis pas de façon péjorative
j'ai des gens ici qui fonce pour la 6e
7e 8e fois qui documente et qui font
voyager une équipe de la norvège par
exemple je crois qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure une équipe de l'irlande
mais des journalistes qui rapportent en
direct y en a pas il y en avait ça
dépend des filles quand une expulsion
important pour les pays comme la france
et ces pays qui n'ont pas l'occasion de
un déplacement qui l'animal année on
attend avant de transporter on veut que
le boucher ou à ça y est on l'élève et
vous allez pouvoir arrimer ont laissé
voilà tamara yaya charte sert à mes
côtés ainsi que monsieur andes qui est l
attestent du planétarium rio tinto alcan
charles n'hésitez pas si vous avez des
questions à poser
c'est à dire que on parle du mal de
l'espace quand ils arrivent dans
l'espace mais on parle aussi du mal de
terre quand ils reviennent et david
saint-jacques vous aviez prévenu que
l'oréal ne venez pas bien branlé plus
branché sur le cerveau alors quand tu
reviens tu as dit symptômes qui
ressemblent d'une certaine façon à ce
que tu es ce que tu ressens quand tu vas
dans l'espace et ici il a il à l'aise
c'est clair peut-être est-il en train de
vomir
ça se produit très souvent ce genre de
chose près ce que tu puisses astronautes
ont connu c'est dans l'espace
et quand ils reviennent sur terre c'est
quelque chose qui se produit assez
fréquemment aussi et c'est au cours avec
tous vos mii c'est violent c'est pas
facile surtout dans ces circonstances là
alors ça va prendre quelques minutes
avant qu'il puisse être stabilisé se
sentir mieux et puis être déplacées vers
la tente c'est une hypothèse on en a
tous les faits devant nous n'avons que
ce soit aux et que si ce que c'est
simplement ça qui se produit en ce
moment bah si ce n'est que ça tant mieux
ça aurait peut être évidemment pire
l'important c'est que l'atterrissage je
sois bien produit une bouille et puis
bah il suffit de prendre un transport
quand on est n'importe quel individu on
peut avoir simplement mal des transports
alors imaginons ce qui à travers toutes
les épreuves à laquelle il est passé les
différents changements philosophiques
biologique qui la subit donc c'est
vraiment
probablement dû à ces à ce changement de
l'état là on souhaite très bien je pense
qu'on va avoir des nouvelles dans pas
très longtemps maintenant c'est pas
quelque chose qui se contrôlent nos
astronautes d'apollo l'on nous tous
d'ibn par exemple qui s'est retrouvé à
faire le premier à être le plus parmi
les premiers astronautes a été en orbite
autour de la lune a été violemment
malade ça n'a pas été super avant après
avoir bien des années mais on le sait
aujourd'hui parce que bon tout ça a été
déclassifié les arques les 8 où il va
être très malade pour mener et puis
après ça ça passait et puis son oreille
interne s'est habitué son cerveau s'est
habitué à des sensations complètement
différente
tu sais pas où est le haut le bas la
gauche la droite complètement désorienté
et étourdie ouais alors si c'est comme
sorties d'un gros gros manèges
effectivement la rencontre moi ça m'est
arrivé dans un tournage de découverte et
puis je pense que je me sentais aussi
mal que david saint-jacques sinon on
sait pas dire pire parce que franchement
je me prendrais pour qui et quand même
voir en sorte d'avoir été très mal à
imaginer pour ce manège puissance mais
là aussi ce n'est pas plus alors
qu'avant intéresse qu on a eu un petit
break communication avec elle mais
sachez qu'elle est toujours sur place
tout est à la portée de la baie de saint
jean david saint-jacques à côté d'elle
elle continue de suivre ce qui se passe
on viendra en conversation avec elle un
peu plus tard et peut-être même ici en
compagnie d'hervé de saint jacques qui
sait on lance cette possibilité dans le
cosmos on espère bien que ça se
matérialise on se quitte le temps d'une
courte pause on poursuit avec cette
émission spéciale consacrée au retour
sur terre qui s'est bien produit
heureusement pour david saint-jacques a
tout de suite
[Musique]
fabien de cette émission spéciale
consacrée au retour sur terre de david
saint-jacques revoyons revivons c'est
tout dernier instant voilà le moment où
il lui et ses deux collègues touche le
sol terrestre avec cette parachute qui a
une importance primordiale et tout s'est
bien déroulé et comme on peut le voir
ici c'est de façon verticale
la navette s'est posée ensuite ces
convois d'hélicoptères de véhicules
tout-terrain ce soit et de composés de
médecins et des équipes médicales se
sont rués sur la capsule tamar altéré
secouent notre collègue journaliste
envoyé spécial sur place étaient du
nombre
revoyons maintenant les images du moment
où on a extirpé de la capsule soyouz
david saint jacques disons que ça s'est
un peu moins bien passé que pour admis
clean et me suis cogné un coup qui était
le commandant david saint jacques qui a
été aux prises avec a eu des malaises
des malaises pendant un bon moment déjà
ça semble tranquillement s'estomper mais
on le comprend pour david saint jacques
quelle aventure l'entrée dans
l'atmosphère le choc du retour à la
gravité et on notre notre notre invité
sur le plateau mais fernandez dcri qui
était à la tête du planétarium issia
montréal décrivait la capsule au moment
du retour lan la comparerais plutôt à
une machine à laver avec le mouvement
que ça implique le côté très exigu de
cet espace
il ya des gens qui commandent sur notre
facebook là puisqu'on était web diffusée
en ce moment sur la page facebook de
radio de radio-canada info que c'est
comme assister naissance le moment où on
sort les astronautes de la capsule
certains souhaitent boncourt
ici à david saint-jacques prends ton
temps d'abedi disent certains
internautes et tous sambre en prennent à
plusieurs qui commande cette image
d'anne mclean revenus les pouces en
l'air en applaudissant en ayant hâte
presque de marché de courir dans les
steppes kazakhes
ça s'est produit mais quand même
voilà comment où on en est en ce moment
messieurs on attend toujours une image
de david saint jacques
une fois qu'il sera davantage récupérer
mais tous on le rappelle est normal et
puis quand on n'a pas le mal des
transports
c'est plus facile de bonne humeur et gré
à lever les bras puis de sourire à tout
le monde sur la halle mal des transports
que ce soit dans un véhicule terrestre
où que ce soit dans une capsule soyouz
ramenant sur terre on n'est pas bien
c'est une question d'expérience ni de
santé physique c'est véritablement
chaque organisme c'est ça en fusion
qu'exactement exactement comme les gens
qui ont le mal des montagnes ou
ça dépend pas vraiment de la condition
physique c'est vraiment un problème
physiologique de la personne et qu'il y
ait directement à la personne elle-même
mais pas de sa condition physique ou
soit donc c'est pas étonnant que ça
arrive c'est dommage que ça arrive pour
david on vous conviendrez je lui parlais
de suite mais je pense qu'il faut lui
laisser le temps on l'a attendu 204
jours alors on est capable d'attendre 2
4 jours c'est sans arbitres autour de la
semaine 400 kilomètres au dessus de nos
têtes
aqua vintimille qui me lève km suivi
mais vous savez beaucoup d'astronautes
porte des timbres transdermiques des
patchs comme on dit pour justement
lutter contre le mal des transports
quand ils montrent qu'en tire desservant
la plupart font ça donc c'est pas pour
rien là même les russes bah je connais
l'histoire des astronautes parce que
elle nous est racontée plus facilement
mais pour que je présume que les russes
doivent subir le même genre de problème
c'est pas quelque chose que tu peux
prévoir ni contrôlées et c'est quelque
chose qui passe manifestement david
saint jacques était très très très bien
adapté à l'apesanteur on l'a vu dans
combien de cap sur youtube et et
l'émission découverte vous avez très
bien illustré expliquer sa préparation
et aux quatre coins de la planète
que ce soit de la plongée sous marine
l'exploration de de grottes et de caam
en italie et nous avons d'ailleurs un
documentaire qui sera diffusé à
l'automne a découvert dans lequel on va
raconter quelles sont les expériences
qui l'a mené dans l'espace comment ça
s'est passé là haut avec son
entraînement et cetera
les manoeuvres qu'il a pu exercer qui
ont été parfois assez périlleuse et est
complexe et puis sa réinsertion
psychosocial sur terre cantine ce
maintenant qu'il est revenu
comment va-t-il se réinsérer dans son
groupe de travail dans sa famille qui
n'a pas vu depuis six mois
tout ça fait partie d'ailleurs d'une
étude de canadiennes on étudie comment
les astronautes s'adapte à l'espace mais
aussi comment ils s'adaptent au retour
sur terre et dans ce documentaire là on
va raconter cette histoire là ça va être
diffusé cet automne a découverte donc
david saint-jacques à 40 9 en janvier
dernier
il était loin de sa famille pour cet
instant-là reçu quelques messages je
crois de pierre léon et sophie ses
enfants ainsi que véronique morin son
épouse elle même médecin les deux
partagent alors une passion incroyable
pour le grand nord et la médecine en
région éloignée vraiment des êtres
exceptionnels et que ses astronautes et
les gens qui les entourent aussi parce
que ça prend ces gens là pour les
soutenir dans leur aventure
bien évidemment ça fait partie du
portrait on va devoir se quitter le
temps d'une courte pause mais il ya
tellement intéresse qu à qui on a à qui
on a bien espoirs de parler et elle même
s'entretiendra peut-être aussi avec
david saint-jacques si sa condition
physique le permet bien entendu mais ça
fait partie de nos soins et on y
reviendra après la pause reste et des
autres pour cette émission spéciale sur
le retour d'un vide celle de david
saint-jacques a tout de suite
[Musique]
voilà près de deux heures que se
poursuit cette émission spéciale qui à
travers laquelle vous avez pu
accompagner de minute en minute le
retour sur terre de david singer qui à
21h46 22h46 très précisément dans les
steppes kazakhes
la capsule qui à son bord à laquelle
dans laquelle se trouvait david saint
jacques s'est posé sur le sol terrestre
sans grande embûches des malaises oui à
son arrivée pour david saint jacques
mais il rien de tout ça qui est anormal
on va se tourner vers l'agencé spatiale
canadienne c'est à dire rive sud de
montréal longueuil et sébastien
desrosiers vous étiez sur place de votre
perspective à vous comment été vécu ce
moment très important du retour sur
terre de la vie de saint jacques
ben c'est une soirée forte en émotions
qui se conclut alexis ici à l'agencé
spatiale canadienne au moment où l'engin
s'est posé noir s'il part la rentrée
atmosphérique on a senti à un soupir de
soulagement collectif ici à l'agent
spécial où étaient réunies bon des
membres de la famille de david saint
jacques mais aussi des employés de
l'agencé spatiale canadienne pour qui
prend enfin aussi en quelque sorte cette
longue épopée de près de six mois 204
jours en orbite pour david saint jacques
c'est doit-on le rappeler la plus longue
mission pour un astronaute canadien
alors il ya un certain sentiment de
fierté
ce soir on sent bien qu'ils habitent les
employés de l'agencé spatiale canadienne
ils ont été guidés ce soit à travers
tous et toute cette cette épopée par
deux astronautes dont roberto que le
premier qui avait fait ce voyage il ya
dix ans aujourd'hui et il a fait un
commentaire intéressant sur les étapes
qui attendent david saint jacques au
cours des prochains mois et le dis moi
ça m'a pris six semaines avant de
retrouver une forme physique qu'il
qualifiait de normal donc où il pouvait
faire un jogging par exemple est l'un
des problèmes physiques qui l'a
rencontré à son retour c'est le calcium
qu'ils avaient perdue dans ses eaux
pour ça il dit ça prend un en avant de
retrouver le calcium à 100% la force
complète de nouveau à la une soirée très
intéressante encore une fois forte en
émotions qui se termine
l'agencé spatiale canadienne hu et tout
un exploit pour l' agence au complet
parce que david saint-jacques le répéter
à plusieurs reprises mon succès et celui
de l' ensemble de l' agence spatiale les
canadiens de tout le monde qui travaille
dans cet univers spatial
ici au canada et toute une armée de
personnes et de spécialistes dont une
bonne partie étaient réunis là où vous
étiez où vous êtes en ce moment même l
agence spatiale et tout le monde est
parti à l'heure actuelle avec l'esprit
tranquille n'est ce pas ouais c'est ça
exactement ou du moins ils sont en train
de le faire et non par les bons de sa
réhabilitation physique et aussi des
expériences qui se poursuivent qui
implique des gens de l'agencé spatiale
canadienne donc des expériences
auxquelles ils vont participer au cours
des prochaines semaines après qu'ils
soient revenus à houston donc aux
quartiers généraux de la nasa
mais encore une fois là c'est tout un
exploit qu'a accompli david
saint-jacques aujourd'hui mais si tout
un exploit qui accomplit également l'
agence spatiale canadienne et si le
commentaire qui est ressorti des
entrevues qu'on a fait un peu plus tôt
avec les astronautes canadien robert
thirsk est aussi jeremy hansen qui lui a
été nommé en 2009 en même temps que
david saint-jacques et qui attend
toujours sa première mission il dit le
l'importance de cette mission pour
l'agencé spatiale canadienne c'est un
peu entre autres d'inspirer les jeunes
et on en a vu des enfants ici ce soir
des jeunes chez pas qu'il y avait entre
8 et 14 ans qui à la sortie nous disait
être inspiré en quelque sorte parce qu'a
fait david david saint-jacques et bat
alexis ce seront eux les astronautes de
demain voilà qui est bien dit un
excellent point de chute à notre
conversation sébastien d'érosion vous
remercie beaucoup pour votre
contribution de cette émission spéciale
sébastien merci on appris au revoir à
voir et ben oui c'est tout un exemple
pour les jeunes les jeunes canadiens
d'air et s'est entretenu à de nombreuses
reprises david saint jacques avec des
écoliers d'un bout à l'autre du pays et
qui ont pu l'entendre lui poser
directement des questions et à chaque
fois à tout coup ce qu'on remarque c'est
cette capacité qu'il a de connecter avec
les gens de communiquer ses
connaissances
et vraiment les connaître les
connaissances les plus fines qu'il peut
avoir dans tous les champs de compétence
qui le domine killer hui qu il domine
qu'ils maîtrisent plus tôt on va
d'ailleurs voir ensemble un peu calé le
pédigré de cet homme exceptionnel qui
david saint jacques
cet homme qui n'est donc qu'en janvier
1970 à québec a grandi à saint lambert
et rive sud de montréal baccalauréat en
génie physique
pourquoi pas ajouté aux enchères
doctorat en astrophysique un doctorat en
médecine comme si ne n'est pas celle ce
n'était pas ainsi que vous voyez là le
portrait d'un homme fondamentalement
curieux assoiffé de connaissances un
passionné tous à la mène et l'amener en
tant que médecin au centre de santé de
un centre de santé qui est situé au
nunavik c'est d'ailleurs là qu'il a
rencontré son épouse qui est elle aussi
médecin avec qui il partage cette
passion de médecine dans des endroits
très régulier madame morin dr murray
véronique morin il était recruté en mai
2009 par l' agence spatiale canadienne
et c'est là véritablement que le premier
pas vers son rêve d'astronautes qui
l'entretient d'un plat tendre enfance a
été franchie astronautes de soutien ça
c'est très important dans sa progression
de la mission expédition 35 36 en 2013
il assurait donc les communications
entre si on veut le centre d'opérations
ici sur terre et ce qui se passait là ou
bien au dessus de nos têtes il était
affecté en mai 2016 à la mission
expédition 58 qui vient de prendre fin
aujourd'hui quelle aventure
pour david saint-jacques vous avez eu
messieurs ou deux la chance de le
rencontrer en personne c'est pas tout le
monde qui a pu le rencontrer mais je
peux la chance d'apporter le privilège
rencontré comment décrire en quelques
mots j'ai rencontré brièvement à ottawa
ya environ deux ans et j'ai été frappé
par son charisme sa simplicité son
authenticité
c'est un homme très chaleureux une
présence physique impressionnante
quelqu'un qui est très en forme c'est
l'athlète dans le fond ils étaient là
avec sa femme et ses enfants
et c'était très attendrissant dé voir
ensemble mais je vais parler quelques
minutes seulement je pense que lille
connaît mieux
je le connais pas forcément mieux en
fait les rencontres et passent pas
beaucoup
d'infos en fait et la dernière fois
c'était l'année passée au centre des
sciences et j'ai vraiment pu le côtoyer
pendant quelques minutes et il donne de
son temps et moi ce que je retiens de
cet homme c'est qu'il est avant tout
généreux et humain très humain est ce
quelqu'un de brillant
qui a aussi un doctorat en astrophysique
comme moi je suis fier quoi jaser
j'ai aussi un bac en génie physique mais
je me suis arrêté là jamais trop tard et
jamais trop tard pour continuer mais bon
mais le mais c'est vraiment quelqu'un de
généreux humains brillant et il
représente tellement bien le québec
regardez comme un communiqué donc avec
ces jeunes chez ces sujets de regarder
les battements l'émerveillement dans
leurs regards dans leur visage c'est un
peu ça aussi la mission d'un astronaute
neil a été d'une très grande générosité
il aurait pu le faire à quelques
reprises mais il a fait systématiquement
avec de très nombreux en france
encore une fois partout à travers le
pays est en ondes courtes aussi les
communiquer avec les jeunes par ondes
courtes ce qui est vraiment pas mettre
parce que finalement il est à 400 km
d'altitude la station
et quand tu passe au dessus d'une région
où il ya des amateurs dont le cours
demain tu peux communiquer avec eux et
c'est ce qu'il a fait avec de nombreux
jeunes et ça c'est assez remarquable et
sa capacité d'expliquer simplement de
vulgariser le plaisir qu'il a à parler
de connaissances et de savoirs c'est un
homme clairement qu'ils adorent acquérir
des connaissances qui veut comprendre il
le dit lui même il a souvent dit comment
les choses fonctionnent et en même temps
qu'ils aient l'humilité d'aller pendant
un an ou deux comme ça dans un village
inuit dans le nord du québec où nunavik
pour s'occuper d'une communauté qui
avait besoin d'un médecin et il parle il
a pour la loire il n'était pas dans une
sur spécialité a revu la hilton est là
parce que c'est un passionné
c'est quelqu'un que la mention de ce
qu'il fait c'est un passionné
effectivement qu'il est décrit très bien
être passionné revu ma wii alors un
homme aussi qui vient d'arriver et ça ne
semble pas être facile son retour sur
terre dans la mesure où x ça s'est passé
ça s'est bien passé
règle générale mais a subi quelques
malaises qui tout à fait normal en ce
moment même c'est ce que nous disait
tamar altérer ce qu à qui on va parler
un peu plus tard je l'espère bien on
prend soin de lui à toute une équipe qui
l'entourent et peut-être à terme alors
qu'on voit ici les images de sa sortie
de la capsule c'est bienvenu oui c'est
lui
ben à terme on sera peut-être mesure
donc 2
le lui parler on le souhaite pour lui
qu'il se rétablisse le plus rapidement
passé voyez le moment où on l'a fait
glisser sur cette petite glissoire là et
voilà
et par la suite on a pris soin de lui on
l'a vu un peu moins si on veut énergisé
que ses collègues notamment l'allemand
madame mclean qui est dans une forme
assez impressionnante dans les
circonstances voyez le visage blême
quand même les traits tirés après avoir
effectué cette descente à une vitesse
folle et dans une dédiée dans cette
entrée dans l'atmosphère à des temps de
température qui avoisine les 2000 degrés
l'a7 à 38 degrés quand même au
kazakhstan et alors qu'on prend soin de
lui david saint-jacques sa famille et à
houston qu'il va les retrouver assez
rapidement c'est proprement dès qu'il
pourra le faire à ce sera au cours de la
prochaine des prochains dates des
prochaines 24 heures
tam altérer ce qu'on espère du pad après
la pause on doit prendre une courte
pause on se retrouve tous d'après rester
là pour la suite de cette émission
spéciale
[Musique]
de retour et cette émission spéciale la
regarder cette belle terre qui est la
nôtre belle et fragile à la fois vu de
la station spatiale internationale que
quitter davet de saint jacques et le
voilà parmi nous c'est à dire dans notre
dans notre atmosphère à niveau dans
notre monde à nous qui le monde
terrestre ça s'est bien passé pour david
saint-jacques somme toute un peu moins
bien peut-être que c'est ses deux
collègues qui ont déjà assez rapidement
un procédé à la suite des étapes qui
suivent normalement une arrivée comme ça
on va revoir d'ailleurs en images ce le
visage et les noms de ceux qui
composaient et qui faisait partie de
cette petite équipe dans cette petite
capsule de deux mètres par demain tous à
peu près et qui atterrit sur terre de
façon verticale tels que prévu à 22h46
oleg économiques coe le commandant
cosmonaute russe david saint jacques
était le co pilote dans ses manoeuvres
de retour et anne madeleine l'américaine
ingénieur de vol alors pour monsieur
conoco à madame madeleine ça s'est passé
sans grand d'embûches david
saint-jacques a eu des malaises
ce que nous dit aux dernières nouvelles
nettement altérées sco alors qu'on
revoie ici le moment de l'arrivée de la
capsule
s'ils comprenaient bien soin de lui ça
devrait se rétablir sous peu on l'espère
bien pour lui qui va regagner assez
rapidement ses proches donc à houston
qu'il attend de sa femme et ses trois
enfants avec nous je vous le rappelle
ici ah bon le voilà l'image que je
voulais vous remontez remontrer de david
saint jacques au moment où le sort de
cette capsule
il sort de l'écoutille david saint
jacques un peu moins resplendissant un
peu moins animée et que david saint
jacques on a vu pendant six mois nous
parler depuis l'espace et le voilà qui
glisse et qu'il faut le sol le terrain
j'avais a dit il de reçus de sentir le
vent sur mon visage il l'a senti
finalement il peut se sentir rassurés
tout va bien dans l'ensemble
charles tisseyre qui est à mes côtés
c'est un privilège de vous avoir à mes
côtés ainsi que monsieur hernandez qui
est à la tête du planétarium rio tinto
alcan vous en parlait beaucoup au
planétarium ça je l'aimais pression au
cours des prochains jours de ce qui
vient de se vivre à l'essai avec vos
mots
la fai si on veut on va se terminer
cette émission spéciale il a vécu une
expérience extraordinaire marquantes
minaj qui me reste c'est le départ quand
il a dit au revoir à ses coéquipiers qui
reste là haut
comment ils se sont embrassés et la
tendresse qu'ils ont les uns pour les
autres l'ami titre profonde qu'ils ont
les uns pour les autres et ne revivrons
plus jamais ça ensemble parce que
refaire ses équipes ces équipes là ça
sera pas possible très certainement mais
de voir que cet homme là a fait tout ce
qu'il a voulu faire
il a fait brillamment et qu'il est sorti
de là avec je pense le bonheur dans le
coeur mais pour nous aussi c'est tout un
bonheur et un soulagement de le voir
parmi nous de retour à vous monsieur
hernandez voudrais quelqu'un quel
personnage incroyable quelques l homme
impressionnant et puis aussi quelle
équipe aussi impressionnante derrière
lui on voit toute la gent spatiale parce
qu'il ya des dizaines et des centaines
de personnes qui ont travaillé avec lui
et tout son accomplissement personnel
aussi c'est le fruit de
l'accomplissement de toute cette équipe
là qui a travaillé en permanence tout le
temps tout le temps avec lui et puis
c'est ça que je retiens en fait dans ce
dans cette mission là c'est cette
capacité de travailler en équipe de tout
ce groupe là qui a fait des choses
absolument incroyable et qui fait la
fierté en fait deux
du domaine spatial kennedy pour être
chauvin mais c'est une belle vitrine
les examens nationaux du canada tout à
fait tout à fait c'est vraiment une très
belle vitrine et on peut être fier et
bias et donc vous suivrez chardy c'est
avec vos collègues de découverte la
suite des choses pour david saint
jacques
ça va se passer prochaine étape pour lui
à houston retour avec ses enfants et son
épouse merci d'avoir été des nôtres
merci à vous monsieur unique de la
rochelle et continue à suivre notamment
intéressés ok sur place en ce moment au
kazakhstan au revoir et bonne soirée
[Musique]
oh